Movies based on Marvel Comics have been popular
for quite some time now.
Marvel Studios themselves, Fox, Sony Pictures
and various other movie studios have been
responsible for their production and distribution
over the years, but what they all have in
common is the fact that they contain popular
Marvel characters.On the whole, they've been
very good.
Movies based on Marvel properties have tended
to perform better both critically and commercially
than those based on DC properties, for example
- The Dark Knight Trilogy aside - but none
of them are perfect by any stretch of the
imagination.If you look close enough, factual
errors, continuity errors, things being in
shot that shouldn't be, and various other
mistakes are prominent in them all.
This video will take a look at some prime
examples.
Here are ten Marvel movie mistakes the don't
want you to find.
The Avengers
There's a fairly silly continuity error in
The Avengers and it occurs just after the
second engine goes down on the S.H.I.E.L.D.
Helicarrier, following the attack on it by
the mind-controlled Hawkeye and Loki's other
henchmen.
The visual display in Iron Man's helmet shows
the altitude of the Helicarrier as being 15,000
feet and rapidly falling.
However, a short time later, just after a
dying Phil Coulson shoots Loki with the Destroyer
gun, even though it has been falling since
the engine went down, the altitude on the
Helicarrier's bridge shows it as being at
18,000 feet.
Miraculously, it has somehow "fallen" upwards
by more than 3,000 feet in that time.
Guardians of the Galaxy
In Guardians of the Galaxy, when Peter Quill
and Gamora first encounter one another and
get into a fight on the Nova Corps' home planet
of Xandar, Gamora grabs the Orb Infinity Stone
that Quill is carrying and runs away.
Quill throws a laser-based lasso-type device
at her, which snares her legs and causes her
to trip over.
She removes it and, immediately in the next
shot, it has completely vanished from the
ground.
While you might want to argue that it was
a laser and could just have dissipated, It
also had mechanical components, so even if
the laser had vanished, the mechanical pieces
should still have been on the ground.
Deadpool
In 2016's brilliantly irreverent Deadpool,
after Colossus and Negasonic Teenage Warhead
interruped the Merc with a Mouth's interaction
with the villainous Ajax on the bridge, Colossus
handcuffs himself to Deadpool in an attempt
to recruit him to the X-Men.
Deadpool flat-out refuses and even goes as
far as to cut off his own left hand in order
to escape the Russian mutant's clutches.
However, as Deadpool falls from the bridge
into a truck on the freeway below, it's actually
his right hand that's missing.
The CGI guys got that one very wrong indeed.
The Amazing Spider-Man
In The Amazing Spider-Man, after Peter Parker
is bitten by a radioactive spider during a
visit to Oscorp, he takes the subway to get
home.
During the journey, he discovers he has developed
spider-like abilities, such as sharp senses,
incredible reflexes, super-speed and the ability
to stick to things.
Inadvertently, this gets him into a fight
and, at one point, a passenger uses Peter's
own skateboard to hit him.
The passenger in question is a black gentleman
in a T-shirt, but a split second later he
appears to have inexplciably shapeshifted
into a white guy wearing a checkered shirt.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
In X-Men: Days of Future Past, which is set
in 1973, there are a number of factual errors
that don't fit with the date in question.
The most obvious one occurs when Magneto enters
the Robert F. Kennedy Memorial Stadium.
There's a groundskeeper lining a baseball
field there - but that stadium didn't host
baseball in 1973, as the Washington Senators
had moved to Texas to become the Texas Rangers
after the 1971 season.
In 1973, the only team playing there regularly
was the NFL team the Washington Redskins,
so the only lining being done should have
been for a football field.
Ant-Man
Although it's a fictional concept and we allow
for the suspension of disbelief, the principal
of size manipulation in Ant-Man is said to
work on the basis of the space between molecules
altering - the space decreases for shrinking
and increases for enlarging.
This means that objects will weigh the same,
regardless of their size.
Scott Lang couldn't ride an ant, therefore,
and nor could Hank Pym walk around with a
60 tonne tank in his pocket.
Other errors of this nature include Darren
Cross lifting a full grown sheep between his
finger and thumb, and the supersized Thomas
The Tank Engine toy crushing a police car,
which it would actually be far too light to
do any damage to.
Fantastic Four
Let's be honest, the entirety of 2015's awful
Fantastic Four reboot could quite easily be
an entry on this list, as it was a terrible
mistake to have ever made it, but we'd like
to be a bit more specific than that - so let's
go with a particularly well-known mistake
from within the movie.
Due to the reshooting of several scenes in
the movie, Sue Storm's hairstyle, as well
as the texture, length and colour of her hair,
changes from scene to scene, and even at times
from shot to shot.
This was because Kate Mara's hair had been
cut when she was called back for the reshot
scenes and she was actually forced to wear
a wig - which is actually kind of farcical.
Ghost Rider: Spirit of Vengeance
Right at the very beginning of Ghost Rider:
Spirit of Vengeance, Idris Elba's Moreau - a
French priest in the movie - is riding on
a motorcycle with the license plate number
NC-5 753-T. That is clearly visible in close-ups.
However, moments later, as he rides along
a stone road that leads to the monastery he
is heading to, before he passes two guards
at the monestary's entrance, we can see that
the screen has been flipped for some bizarre
reason, as the number plate we had just seen
is briefly written backwards on the screen.
This was obviously either a mistake, or it
was done on purpose without realising that
the audience would be able to tell.
Blade: Trinity
At the start of Blade: Trinity, Blade is framed
for the murder of a human by the vampire community
and he allows himself to be captured and arrested.
After an interrogation proves futile, the
police prepare to hand Blade over to a group
of federal agents who, unbeknownst to them,
are vampires.
He is rescued by Hannibal King and Abigal
Whistler but, during their escape, he heads
to a higher floor in the police station to
find his sword.
He reemerges outside after crashing through
a window and landing dramatically on the concrete,
followed by a lot of glass, which covers the
floor around him.
However, in the next scene, once he stands
upright, the glass around him has weirdly
disappeared.
Captain America: Civil War
Captain America: Civil War was fantastic - one
of the best movies of 2016 and the highest-grossing
one of the year so far - but there's a mistake
in the movie that was even in the trailer
and still made it to the final cut.
When Spider-Man makes his big entrance at
the German airport where the movie's main
battle takes place, he flips through the air
and relieves Captain America of his shield
using his webbing.
However, mere moments later, when he lands
on top of the vehicle holding said shield,
the webbing has mysteriously vanished from
it.
Given how sticky that webbing is, there's
no way even Spidey himself could have removed
it that quickly.
Thanks for watching our list of ten Marvel
movie mistakes the don't want you to find.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other Marvel movie mistakes can you
think of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.